hey guys I'm Ryan Wright tonight I'm
going to be watching the trailer for
World of Warcraft warlords of Draenor
gran or I don't [ __ ] know I'm a little
sick right now but a lot of you guys
have been asking me to check out this
trailer and I've been avoiding it
because I don't know [ __ ] about World of
Warcraft now if you're coming across
this and you're like this guy don't know
anything there's no need to say that in
the comment boxes because I just
established that I'm checking this out
though because what happens a lot of
time when I check out like game trailers
is I never played the game before than I
find myself playing it because the tray
that was so cool everyone loves wow as
you [ __ ] nerds call it I've always
been interested mom kind of I'm really
but everyone's saying this trailers like
[ __ ] amazing so if this trailer
intrigues me I'll probably start playing
it it's like the fifth game so I got a
lot of catching up to do
blood and gore crude humor mild language
use of alcohol it sounds like a
domestically violent game
during air stream claim your destiny
you will all be donors earn what oh damn
must we give in return
everything
uh-oh
we checked this gift
the latest fringes long intervals
Oh God
Oh
you
no [ __ ] three
it's not a destiny times change
then we were made conquerors
first thought I don't know what the [ __ ]
is going on okay
I kind of have an idea it sort of makes
sense but here's what I will say I was
pretty hooked by that like I was sort of
viewing it like watching a teaser clip
of the World of Warcraft series and you
know it's supposed to be like well show
you this clip and if people like it then
they might want to play it and that clip
really made me feel like that like I
don't not entirely sure what's going on
but it's really intriguing it's really
interesting and the graphics are amazing
and there's some badass ranee and
they're first I was like these are
pretty [ __ ] ugly people though play
as I don't know if I want to play as
he's ugly [ __ ] but after a
while I was like there's some cool ugly
[ __ ] so yeah I mean I'll check
it out I mean I've wanted to be part of
the WoW community as if you don't know
the WoW community
you're just a [ __ ] idiot anyway guys
thanks for telling me to check out that
trailer if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe to the real rejects we
have a lot of [ __ ] on there yeah when I
get some shoutouts here mr. James Bourne
jr. he wants a shout out mr. James Bond
jr. you know you probably have a lot of
brothers and sisters if you really think
about James Bond he never seems like
he's really carrying a condom around
with him he seems like he just bones
chicks left and right and he probably
has a lot of children out there in the
world he goes worldwide so I start going
on a mission and find all your brothers
and sisters find all like 48 of you guys
that would be really cool mr. Godzilla
for four or five give me a shout-out if
you don't I will stomp on your
neighborhood and take a radioactive piss
on your lawn the numbers are pronounced
445 so you know I'll be leaving now
thanks for telling me how to pronounce
math that is really awesome
mr. Godzilla I don't want you to stomp
on my neighborhood and take a
radioactive piss on my lawn I have
neighbors here if you stomp on Marie's
apartment that would be okay I mean
she's my neighbor but I love her and
everything but if you were to do some
stomping I I kind of like it if he
stomped on her house her apartment
whatever so figurative Sartre destroyed
some [ __ ] piss on Murray's Adam Gonzalo
us yo Ryan still waiting on a shout out
shout out to me Bubba diesel 24 thanks
man
by the way you're famous Adam Gonzales
Bubba diesel 24 you said on famous I
know I'm famous in the YouTube world
30,000 plus subscribers is just beyond
famous okay I am like legendary Al
Pacino of YouTube in a lot of ways and
at the same time I am the modern-day
version of Ryan Gosling which already
exists he's the modern-day version of
himself and I was stupid but Adam just
know this I'll always love you
and if not I'll like you